[Music]
welcome everybody
my name is Sam Silverberg I'm a cloud
engineer based in Portland Oregon and
I'm lucky enough to have my brother
Aaron Silverberg up on stage with me
we're gonna be presenting about cloud ml
engine for industrial vision inspection
but before we get started I just want to
talk a little bit about how we got to
this point which was my brother and I
were discussing all of the advances in
object detection and machine learning
and Aaron is in in the industrial space
and we thought this is a good
opportunity to team up and come up with
a fund to make it a fun opportunity to
work together thanks for the nice intro
Sam yeah we don't really get the
opportunity to play Legos and GI Joe as
much these days so for us to be able to
work together on something like this is
fun flexible assembly systems is based
in San Diego and we specialize in
designing and building customer robotic
equipment for various manufacturing and
industries whether it be an automotive
bioscience medical device aerospace
defense etc and one thing that all of
these industries that we work with
strive for is better quality higher
throughput better safety standards and
the ability to log vision data now I
have a short video I want to share with
you guys that goes through how machine
learning machine vision and automation
all fit together
welcome to flexible vision
give me a sunflower seed all right
giving your sunflower seed
a Google use flexible vision give me a
peanut
[Music]
all right getting your Canucks
in Google vision what can I get for you
give me a candy almond
are you tired of digging
favorite night well for me this was
happening all too often and I had to
make a drastic change in my life and
with a little help from Google now my
life runs efficient as the Department of
Motor Vehicles but in all seriousness
machine learning and machine vision
really do have the potential to change
the world for the better
so what does peanuts and almonds have
anything to do with machine learning
the answer is machine vision machine
vision today is a 10 billion dollar
globally global industry and is expected
to be 18 billion by 2025 in North
America alone the industry has grown 10
percent this past year this market is
really broken up into two product
categories we have the PC based systems
and all-in-one smart cameras these PC
based systems have a lot of horsepower
capability you have the capability of
plugging in multiple cameras being able
to run all all the cameras in parallel -
and then you also have the flexibility
of being able to swap out lenses and
lighting to cater it to your vision
inspection application and on the other
side we have the all-in-one smart
cameras they're a really nice tight
package that have everything built-in
they have the processing the lighting
and the lensing all in a nice form
factor but you do lose out on the
horsepower and you are limited to
obviously the one unit for your location
now these are real life examples that I
have up on screen this the first example
is a medical device that we were doing a
hundred percent inspection on these
products as they were going out the door
and it's a silicone injection molded
part that was prone to under molding and
this under molding would be not enough
material was injected in the injection
mold process and so we had two cameras
were mounted perpendicular to each other
taking a picture simultaneously and
getting a throughput of one per second
on
operation the second example is an
automotive application this is a
electronic device that goes into
vehicles and there's process that
requires thermal paste being applied to
this product before it goes into the
automated machinery and so we decided to
use an all-in-one smart camera for this
application to detect that thermal paste
and give the robot the okay to go ahead
with the operation another way these
cameras are used is for robot guidance
the this is an example of a camera
mounted on the end of a robot to give it
coordinates on where it should go and
this is doing server assembly and we
were looking at some fiducials on the
printed circuit board to decide where
those parts could go with great accuracy
and other examples might be picking and
placing car bumpers from a moving from a
rack onto a moving assembly line picking
up placing horns onto a sub assembly
inspecting a bead of adhesive to verify
that it's a solid bead of adhesive and
then being able to read barcodes and OCR
here I have up on screen two examples of
today's programming interfaces and on
the Left I have a this is more of a
drag-and-drop this is you have your
pallet of tools that you would drag and
drop onto your screen and create your
program in a tree like structure and
over on the right hand side is an
example of more of a spreadsheet style
programming where you can import
functions and do more of a programming
and a spreadsheet both are based on the
idea of having a palette of tool sets
being able to pull those tool sets into
your program then manipulate them and
the thought has always been - in order
to add more capability add more tool
sets now I'm going to quickly go through
kind of today's process on how we
program vision systems today and
essentially what we're doing is we're
looking at a bitmap image
of a picture there have been
advancements in the industry to
triangulate between bitmap locations to
give you higher accuracy that this is
the product the this is the image that
you're looking for but essentially what
we're looking at is taking a an image
bitmap and comparing it to one that
we've trained against first step is to
define your camera lighting and lensing
and adjusting your aperture for your
application then we can go into the
programming and programming one of the
first steps we typically do is the
calibration if it's going to be used in
coordinated motion between a camera and
a robot you want to be able to take
those coordinates and give them
real-life coordinates that the robot can
interpret then you'll use just like we
talked about a minute ago we'll use the
drag and drop from our pallet onto
screen to create our program for example
these pallet tools might include a
circle tool if you're trying to define a
golf ball moving down an assembly line
you might use a circle tool to tell the
system hey I'm looking for a round
object or a dispensing a dispense bead
you might use the line tool for
something like that or a histogram tool
if you're trying to figure out how
bright or dark something is and you'll
add these tools and create your program
and you might include some pre filters
to make those pixels pop out a little
bit better and then it's ready to run
and we run through the snap and find
routine and it's not really until we get
to the thousands thousands one that we
really feel comfortable with hey this
program that we created is going to work
for our assembly line and keep in mind
that false positives are a part of life
in this industry so why is that well the
systems today are suspects of lighting
conditions we have
whether he imagined you're near factory
floor you have a skylight and the
lighting changes throughout the day well
you have to account for that in your
software program and your vision program
so that as those lighting conditions
change that you are still successfully
finding the model as you intended camera
orientation is important if that camera
happened to get bumped that is an
environmental issue that you might have
to overcome and like I had mentioned
earlier that the the the operators
because you have these false positives
operators on the assembly line tend to
open up tolerances that you've built
into your software program to alleviate
their jobs to get the product out the
door but what they're really doing is
opening up the opportunity for failed
product to be going out the door it's
also very difficult to detect any object
with variability like you saw earlier
with the peanuts the anything organic
like fruit is very difficult castings
are another difficult object to find
because sometimes they come out shiny or
dull or have additional flashing on them
and logging of data is such a value and
it's it's underserved in the market
today mainly because it's not accessible
it the the application is there but it's
up to the engineers that are building
their software programs to make that
connection to the cloud what efficients
vision systems were less difficult to
maintain easier to share programs across
factory floors camera resolutions
weren't as critical lighting and
environmental variables were less of an
issue systems were less expensive and
the same system that you're at home
sorting Legos with your children is the
same system that you're using at an
automotive Factory detect scratches on
trim is open source the solution
well tensorflow is a great object
detection tool
OpenCV is good for measurement and
calibration node-red is a good logic
control and allows you to connect to
peripheral devices tez errect OCR is the
number one optical recognition software
available today and z-bar is a good tool
for reading barcodes but not one of
these is a silver bullet each one of
them comes with its own steep learning
curve and integration between them is
non-existent we wanted to crack this nut
by democratizing the the industrial
vision market removing the technical
barriers to entry literally harnessing
the ml engine and bringing an on-prem
when needed
simplifying the setup creating an
all-in-one easy to use graphical user
interface I wanted to make it flexible
and modular by providing an open API
being able to use any USB camera and
keeping it low cost by keeping it open
source using low-cost CPUs and an edge
devices being able to train in the cloud
instead of on-prem integrated cloud and
open source is the future to industrial
vision we are super excited to be
releasing an open-source version of
flexible vision which meets all of our
democratizing objectives it has endless
market potential opens the door to use
cases that weren't previously available
whether it be to pricing constraints or
functionality in the market vision
models can now be shared across factory
floors globally and version control is
built in the system is automation ready
and can communicate directly with robots
and PLC's on factory floors I have a
short five-minute video I'm going to go
through the software
and then I'm gonna pass it over to Sam
and Sam's really going to go into the
ins and outs of the software and how
we're using Google cloud and Google
components to bring it all together so
the very first thing that we're gonna do
is we're gonna plug in a USB camera and
it shows up automatically under
connected devices and then you'll see we
can see the camera and we're gonna
change the resolution we can go up to 4k
resolution on this but keep in mind that
the lower the resolution the faster the
processing and this is an optional step
but the camera calibration is required
for robotic guidance so we take we can
coordinate we can take the pixel
location and convert it to millimeters
and also take any skew and angle
rotation so we could pass that
information to the robot so we could
pick up correctly and then if we go back
to the camera screen we could see that
it is calibrated and we could see the
conversion from pixels to millimeters
and the rotation that we saw earlier all
right now the fun stuff we're going to
create a project and we're going to call
this nut training and the next step is
to start taking some images of these
nuts so we're going to select the camera
and select the project that we want to
associate all these images to and we're
gonna sprinkle out some peanuts randomly
oriented take a snapshot of that and
then we'll sprinkle out some almonds
and we'll do that one more time with
some walnuts
and now we're going to move into the
image annotation this was we ready we're
gonna tag the images and tell the system
what each one of these items are so we
do have some icons over on the left that
tell us that these images have not been
tagged yet and we have a whole whole lot
of nice tool sets built into this GUI so
but the very first thing we'll do is
we'll create the tag names and this tag
is going to first of all be peanuts and
we're gonna do a box detection and just
simply drag and drop we're gonna go
through and select these peanuts
and then we'll do the same thing for
almonds and like you saw earlier what we
were creating these tags there were a
few other checkbox we could have put in
there there's object there's object
detection which we're doing right now we
have OCR and barcode reading all built
in we also have some other tool sets
like a zoom feature which allows you to
if you're trying to do a small
components on a PCB that were difficult
to to see we have this this lure that
you can drag and drop and now we're
ready to start the augmentation process
this is where we're going to take just
these three images and augment them and
give them some variables to to create
thousands of images from these just
three images
and click export data here we have a
pop-up box which would gives us some
variables that we could punch in if we
wanted to change how these images were
being augmented if we want to be able to
rotate them or scale them differently we
could put those parameters in here but
the default settings seem to work pretty
well and you'll notice at the top of the
screen we have a indicator that says hey
something's going on this preview
pre-training is a pretty quick process
it only takes 30 seconds or so and you
can see that that's been completed and
we can go to the image detection page
and you could date image data set excuse
me and you can see that now we have
those thousands of images created
then we're going to take these augmented
images and export them for model
training again we have a small dialog
box that allows you to change a few
settings but we'll just keep it again as
default
in this process happens up in the cloud
and it can take anywhere between 20
minutes to an hour and a half depending
on the model that you're training and
will come back and now we have will see
that if we go to our excuse me list
projects we'll see that the project
project is done and we can assign a
model to it the reason we did it this
way is we wanted to have that version
control built in so in a future date as
you're refining your models I'm making
them better and better that you can go
back and update that and now we're ready
that's really the last step and now
we're ready just to capture and run
select the camera select the project
that we're interested in running and
there you have it it's that easy to
create your models this is you'll see in
just a minute here we're going to break
apart some of these walnuts and the
detection is absolutely amazing and with
that I'm going to pass it over to Sam so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
through a little some of the concepts
that were required to unbe understood in
order to make all this happen as well as
is the underlying architecture from both
an on-prem and from a Google cloud
perspective but before I do let's talk a
little bit about flexible vision and
what flexible assembly is releasing
today and it's an open source package
that provides end and training all the
way through prediction that includes
camera calibration it also includes
object detection object localization OCR
scanning and barcode scanning and it
leverages ml engine in the cloud google
kubernetes engine to perform that
augmentation and training process Google
Cloud storage to store the images
obviously in persistence and then
finally on Prem we're doing the
prediction this is what the overall
architecture looks like and specifically
what you saw in the case of
the initial video Aaron showed which is
that all the way on the left here so on
the left yeah on the left is are the
rope is the robot or the IOT devices
that you will be manipulating the data
from the camera in the middle or the
next slide next over you what you have
is the workflow engine the workflow
engine in the case of what we did is
node red so net node red is a nice
drag-and-drop tool to do IOT integration
but it can be any host of different
tools there and then you have your local
prediction server in case of flexible
vision micro services are heavily
leveraged and each one of the different
components is actually a docker
container in and of itself
now prediction locally on Prem is
important specifically for industrial
applications because you read need very
quick sub hundred millisecond cycle
times that round-trip time to the cloud
may not suffice within those
circumstances and finally all the way to
the right you have all the components
are in Google Cloud you have everything
from like I said kubernetes engine it's
responsible for training coordination
and augmentation Google Cloud Storage
that's responsible for all the
persistence ml engine that's dead doing
the actual training itself and then
finally what you saw is Aaron initiated
the entire process using Google home
initiated through dialog flow and that's
also represented here so let's talk
about the main underlying concepts
that's required as part of this as far
as what you've seen today and that is
object localization or object detection
commonly referred to there are a lot of
open-source libraries that allow you to
do object detection but the one that was
selected for this project was tensor
flow object detection API this is an
open source API that's provided by
Google and is on github and it
essentially provides bounding boxes
around images as well as what's called
instant segmentation what I mean by
bounding boxes is what you see in this
picture those boxes
around the images themselves that
identify what those objects are there's
a lot like I said there's a lot of
object detection models but let's drill
in just quickly on a couple examples and
how this all works together there are
two steps to this process there's
actually quite a few but the first big
step here is actually identifying
candidates for objects that you're going
to want to do some detection process on
and let's talk about single-shot
detection single-shot detection is a
very fast method of identifying objects
and images by using a small
convolutional network to come up with
candidates of possible objects that
could be in that picture this is really
useful for small form-factor or low
computational power systems such as cell
phones or TP use edge GPUs it's not so
good at detecting small objects but is
fine at detecting larger objects and
pictures the second method is faster are
CNN and this works differently than SSD
and that it doesn't use a single shot it
actually does post-processing of the
image to find potential candidates in
those pictures and the way it works is
finding anchor points in those images
and detecting foreground versus
background to come up with those
possible candidates of objects in those
images once those candidates are
identified the second step is actually
to do the prediction that is what is in
those objects themselves and that's the
same whether you using SSD or faster are
CNN let's talk about two possible
methods for doing that there's quite a
few but these are two that are probably
the most common
the first is ResNet rezident is a deep
neural network they can go to a hundred
and one layers and beyond in terms of
its death it's very good at detecting
detail it's very good at accuracy of
detection and an image the second is
inception an inception instead of being
deep is a wide neural network there are
also deep and wide neural networks enter
deception base but essentially you can
kind of think of them as rather than
going deep going wide regardless of what
neural network you decide to attach to
the detection process you're going to
want to measure to see how accurate
these networks are and the primary way
of doing this is using what's called
mean average precision mean average
precision is a combination of the three
elements that you see here in the in the
slides
the first being precision that is are
the objects in the picture that are they
are are they what they're telling me
they are the second is recall because is
it seeing everything it's supposed to
see in the picture and then finally is
intersection of Union intersection of
youjin measures how much of the bounding
box is around the object is it too much
area is a too little area or is it just
right all three of those components are
combined together to come up with this
mean average precision and you'll see
this quite often as an example what you
see here in terms of measuring accuracy
the second key component is once you've
identified those objects now you have to
put them in real space and how this is
done is by translating those pixels
whereas the bounding boxes are in two
millimeters in addition to that you need
to orient the robot in the case of the
video that Aaron showed to the camera so
that they're oriented in the same
location at the same angle and this is
all done through a calibration process
now the way that flexible vision does it
is by using a checkerboard - I do the
calibration what I mean by calibration
is identifying the angle of the camera
to the surface that you're doing the
detection on in addition to that you
want to be able to align the rotation of
whatever is the device that's doing the
pick in place with the robot I'm sorry
with the camera and that requires a
second step in the case of flexible
vision that will
Lyman is done using a QR code why is
this important because like I said
object detection is the basis upon which
an inspection
industrial applications using machine
learning will be built once you've
identified an object in space you can
then do OCR scanning you can then do
barcode scanning you can then do
pick-and-place and quality assurance on
those objects because you've correctly
identified them and you have confidence
that they are what they say they are so
that's why that process is so important
so now we're going to go through step by
step and a little bit more detail about
what's happening under the covers and
why all these steps are required in
order to do object detection the reason
this is important is it doesn't matter
if you're using the open source flexible
vision or if you guys are building your
own tool the steps are essentially going
to be the same and the first step in
that process is doing the tagging this
is the idea of dragging and dropping
bounding boxes around the objects that
you're most interested in in the
pictures that you've collected in the
case of flexible vision those pictures
are collected from the work cell that
you're actually going to do the
detection at or you can upload them to
Google Cloud storage
in either case once you've collected
those pictures you're going to want to
do this bounding box process and the
bounding Braque box process basically
does three essential things it
identifies the objects for training it
also identifies a label that you want
associated with those objects and then
finally you're gonna select an action
that you want would want performed once
those objects are identified those
actions might be just strictly
identifying the object or it might be
again doing OCR scanning or barcode
scanning one question that comes up
quite often is how many objects do I
need or how many pictures do I need in
order to get a good training and that
really depends on the type of objects
that you're doing detection on
as an example luckily and in the
industrial space many objects are well
defined in terms of their edge and shape
and they don't vary very much in those
cases you may only need three to ten
images in other situations where you're
doing quality assurance and the type of
failures may vary quite greatly between
different scenarios you may need quite a
few different images or samples of those
in order to get a good training it may
be up to 100 images the second step to
this process requires two phases and we
called the training process but it's
actually two phases the first is doing
image augmentation and the second is to
actually doing the machine learning
training itself image augmentation is
not always required but is really nice
to have because what it does is it
reduces the variability associated with
environmental variables like Erin
mentioned if you have a skylight and the
lighting might change day to day during
the day or if the camera angle at the
time that you're doing the training is
different than the camera angle at the
time that you're actually doing the
detection and production having done
this augmentation is a really nice thing
to have what essentially performs is
skewing or scaling image contrast or
rotation another nice aspect of doing
this augmentation process is you might
take a sample size of say about a
hundred images and it might explode to a
thousand images based on each
augmentation has a new image in and of
itself so you actually end up with a
larger sample size and once you have
that process complete then you would
actually go through the training itself
now the training itself is fairly
straightforward from the perspective of
you've already done all the hard work
the trainings done all biml engine in
this case now what happens on the back
end is that ml engine is spinning up in
the case of flexible vision
thirty two simultaneous GPU servers to
perform a training in about an hour now
if you compare that to what if you ran
it on your own GPU that might take 16
hours the other benefit of this is that
once you do the training if you need to
retrain or if you need to retrain it's
very quick as well so it's a good
benefit to doing it that way now let's
talk about the third step the third step
in this process is actually to do the
production prediction in production in
order to do this prediction in
production let's talk a little bit about
the flow itself and let's talk about
what Aaron showed in that first video
that is the picking and placing of the
nut so he initiated that process using
Google Howe Google home then triggered
dialogue flow which is in Google Cloud
which then triggered a pub/sub event a
pub/sub event is a topic that is
listened to by external sources that
will thaton contain some data that
pub/sub event was listened to by node
read node read again is an IOT workflow
engine it's open source but you can use
any IOT workflow engine in this case
once it was triggered it then called a
REST API that was on a flexible vision
server that that said take a snapshot
and returned to me the bounding box is
associated with image objects that you
found in an image with that flexible
event vision then triggered a snapshot
from the camera returned back the
results that were found within
tensorflow
those results included the bounding
boxes and some binary digit associated
with the bounding boxes themselves
flexible vision then use that
information to return back the location
in space that is the location
milimeters the textual label of
associated with those bounding boxes in
addition it returned it will return back
OCR scan or barcode scan data as well
all that the data is returned back to
node read in a form of a JSON document
and then finally node read then commands
the robot to move to a specific spot
based on a midpoint of a bounding box
and then returned back the night in
question so now I'm going to turn it
back over to Aaron and he's gonna close
things up
so we are super excited to be releasing
this software and we really can't wait
to see what you all use to use this
software for it's with flexible vision
we've simplified the process we've
democratized machine learning and
machine vision and again we want to see
in education we want to see where we
would want to see universities using
this technology and taking it out into
the workforce we can't wait to see
pathologists and radiologists using
these this technology to find rare
diseases and in the industrial space we
want to we want to be able to change and
collect the data associated with all of
our customers needs and in home
automation we we can't wait for you guys
to find out when you're low on milk so
with that we appreciate everyone's time
today and thank you very much I'm going
to open it up to questions so yeah we're
we're open to questions if anybody has
any questions on implementation details
or other aspects
[Applause]
[Music]